I remember I mean I hated you probably
give you good reason snake Patrick come
here I have a question for you
my old boss at BuzzFeed reached out and
they are wondering if you and I would
like to make a video for them they want
us to be happy for you don't want to do
it so in November of 2007 my mom and I
moved to Arizona from Mexico in part
because most of her family does live
here but mainly because she was gonna
marry my stepdad Patrick my dad died
when I was three years old so I was
really used to seeing her with anybody
but I do remember for most of my
childhood craving a father figure I
think however that by the time my mom
get married with Patrick that craving
had really faded away and that was no
longer something that I really wanted so
I think that's where me and him kind of
bumped heads so for this type of video
usually we have handcuffs but because I
am very unprepared and with very low
resources I went to a store and got zip
ties maybe this will also be a little
more discreet but we have this story I'm
a little bit not so happy
[Music]
yes let me walk back in okay so it's
time for us to get tied so for the 24
hours that we spent together I decided I
would do a list of activities that we
would do together and one of them would
be make dinner for my mom but in order
to do this we had to go to the store and
get some groceries what are your first
thoughts
my first thought sir it's a little
strange
are you embarrassed to go in the store
like this yeah no I think yeah are you
gonna save somebody after smile well
we're not having um we're except I'd
I've done this before and last time was
really embarrassing but it's different
because there I was with my friends and
if you like in LA you see a lot of crazy
stuff sometimes and people are just more
down with it
I think Arizona
[Music]
that wasn't that bad talk about our
relationship and how he entered our
family while painting a picture of my
mom
your mother was visiting and your aunt
who I work with mentioned your mother
wanted to go out dancing so we agreed to
meet at Chili's at Chili's I felt
something for your mom
not a lust thing I never had a feeling
like that my god
translating out for a friend and I wrote
a card to your mom in Spanish saying I'd
like to get to know her to me if
somebody listened to the country before
like if I want to get to know them like
what what that's gonna be hard if I
didn't really think of that you know
it's because I didn't know what was
we're making meatballs on my mom got
this recipe from the risk course it was
coffee in Bangor Maine here yeah that
place does this actually my favorite
mother all right
tying seasoning oh that fresh parmesan
Romano cheese so you want to bet you
stick to smell it yeah
[Music]
your mom had been up here probably once
or twice already and then one time she
brought you and I remember your mom came
over it's a man I was really excited I
got a dad Oh through dating and kind of
cringy that's funny it was funny to me
when do you think you finally got to
meet when we lived here pretty much and
that was kind of turbulence in the
beginning I think there was a little
jealousy on both of our sides did we
have a relationship it's hard anyway but
then when you get kids like a blended
family there's an expert
I don't extra issues that you gotta
learn to work and then there was the
language barrier also before eating
dinner I wanted to sit down and play
never have I ever
okay so the first one is never have I
ever gone skinny-dipping where never
have I ever peed my pants past childhood
I have never have I ever done drugs
that's right I've tried I've tried I've
tried this body always release their
least favorite I never have I ever had
sex in a car
oh my relationship with you what do you
think it was at its worst I mean in
first few years did you at any point
think because of her kiss you
relationship with my mom would not work
I don't know if you know this me and
your mom are gonna break up to you
I didn't know I didn't think was solely
breaking up for the kids it was just the
language barrier the kids I was trying
to build a relationship with your mom
and then there's you in it and in my
mind at the time Wesley this kid this
kid is just in our way to everything
yeah not only did I don't mean it no I
know what you mean salt you know what I
mean about you yeah glad you invited me
to go shooting last Saturday or our few
Saturdays ago and I didn't go because
I'm not a big fan of shooting but I
figured this time maybe it's a good time
for us to go shoot the gun I've never
shot a gun and I'm actually very scared
see the thing is like I don't think
there's anything wrong with guns I think
that's fine like it goes against know
you're a Democrat and you have a gun but
I kind of moderate right than you right
because there's many things on both
sides believe how you want I think it is
a misconception for people to say that
like left-leaning people don't want guns
at all because it's not even about that
I think guns are fine but sometimes in
this country if it becomes so accessible
to everybody if we didn't have mass
shootings I assure you
a lot more people with the super award
with guns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay slide it all the way back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't look comfortable okay stand up
straight
if you want to shoot bring your hand
down don't bring your body right after I
got comfortable shooting that tiny gun
I agree to a lesson with we just left
the shooting range yeah I was I was
shaking at first because it's really
scary I was worried that there would be
bullets flying from the sky because if
you shoot above you know but I
I know my mom was just horrified when
you got in fights we're getting it along
Princeton's now I live in LA and knowing
that she has you and like you guys
travel and do all that stuff together it
brings peace to me and it's kind of
selfish but it's a one of the big
reasons why I'm so happy that we won't
pass through because she has a partner
but my relationship with you I think has
also gotten much better like I generally
am happy that you're in her family but
glad to hear that we still got a lot of
women to do so but I went were on the
right track to have a pretty happy rest
of our life
I think I'm happy for you guys buddy any
song dude Toki
time is a river story in me now into the
darkness chasing sound of